Chandler: Welcome, everyone.
My name is David Chandler.
I work with the Google
Web Toolkit team in Atlanta,
and today, John LaBanca and I
are gonna be talking
about some ways to improve
the performance
of your GWT apps.
I want to acknowledge,
at the outset here,
uh, we recognize
that we're competing
with another great GWT session
across the hall,
the gaming program session with
Phil Rogers and Ray Cromwell,
and, uh, we'd like
to be there, too... [laughs]
'cause they're doin'
some cool stuff,
so I promised to do at least
one cool visual demo for you
during this talk, uh,
so you can get something--
some eye candy out of it.
So we're gonna talk first about
why does speed matter?
Just some interesting numbers
related to your page load times
and exit times.
We'll look at
5 performance pitfalls.
A few of these,
you may have seen
from previous I/O conferences,
and then there's
some new stuff, as well.
Then we'll talk about the new--
John will talk about
the new cell widgets,
uh, in GWT 2.1 and following.
We'll look at activities
and places
and code splitting
as a technique
to improve your
application's performance,
and then finally,
some compiler tips
at the end of our talk.
So first of all,
why does speed matter?
This is an interesting graph
from wikia.com.
They measured the exit rate
at their site
versus the load time,
and showed that as the load time
approached five seconds,
they would lose up to 20%
of their users.
Now Google did a test
once upon a time
of this same thing, and we had
more dramatic numbers.
People asked for 30
search results, instead of 10,
and that increased the load time
half a second
for the first page
of search results,
and what we measured
in small experiments
was that, over a 6-week period,
that resulted in a 25% decline
in the first-page
search results.
So that would be
about $2 1/2 billion,
at the time
the test was conducted,
in revenue for Google,
so we were quite
concerned about that
and we did not go out
with 30 search results.
That's why you still see 10 as
the default on your page today.
So let's talk about
some performance pitfalls.
The first one, related to this,
is don't lose the user
at startup.
HTTP requests is the slowest
thing you can do in the browser.
There's no JavaScript operation
that takes as long
as going to the server and back.
So one of the techniques,
which has been around in GWT
for quite a while,
is to use ClientBundle
to minimize trips for images
and CSS resources.
Chris Ramsdale showed
that technique in more detail
in his talk
this morning on mobile,
but basically,
it's a simple interface
where you can combine
all of your images
and resources together,
and then GWT will make
only one trip to the server
and split them all out
on the client
instead of making
individual requests
for each image in CSS.
Another technique you can do
is to prefetch data
that's needed by your first
page at load time,
so one easy way to do this is,
instead of hosting your GWT app
in a static HTML page,
you can host it in a JSP page,
for example,
and then any data that your--
your GWT app is gonna need,
uh, just right off the bat,
you just write in
as JavaScript variables
into the host page,
and then you can use
the GWT dictionary class
to read those JavaScript
variables from your GWT app,
or you can use
JSNI methods, as well,
to do that.
We've recently written
an article on this
on the GWT code site,
uh, that you can check out
and get more info
on that technique.
Okay, a second big
performance pitfall
is don't lock up the browser.
JavaScript is single-threaded,
and so you don't want
the browser to become
unresponsive to user input,
and that means
you have to be careful,
uh, when writing your GWT code.
So Scheduler is the new feature
that was--replaces
the timer feature
in the older versions of GWT,
and there's a method,
scheduleDeferred,
that will wait until
the browser event loop runs,
and then it will run your code
after that, so this--by--
instead of just doing everything
inline in your GWT code,
if you occasionally use
scheduleDeferred
to defer some operations,
then that will give users
a chance to respond.
This is sometimes also required
as a workaround
for focus and layout issues.
Some of the widgets, like--
I know, a text box,
if you call SetFocus true on it,
um, then it may not actually
take effect in some browsers
until after
the event loop runs,
so you have to use
scheduleDeferred
and then SetFocus true,
and then it will happen.
Okay, for repetitive UI work,
uh, similarly here, you don't
want to use a for loop
to do, say, an animation frame,
because that would
make the browser
completely unresponsive
to user input.
So instead, you're gonna
have a while loop,
and then for each frame,
the--the command
to draw a frame,
you would put in
a scheduleFixedPeriod,
for example,
and that would execute it
once every 5, 10,
15 milliseconds,
however often you specify.
There's also a method
that's useful in the Scheduler
called scheduleFinally,
that will execute code
before the browser repaint,
uh, event loop runs,
and this is good
for coalescing calls,
so if you had several calls that
manipulate the DOM, for example,
then you could
use scheduleFinally
to have them all run together,
and that would reduce flicker,
as well as limit
the amount of actual
DOM activity that's required
in the browser.
Okay, number 3--Don't make
two trips when one will do.
What we're talking about here
is batching of calls
to the server.
So with GWT-RPC,
you can do this using
the Command pattern,
and there's lots of frameworks
out there for that GWT dispatch.
Actually, there's a few
frameworks for that.
The gwt-dispatch is one
that's been very popular,
uh, lets you send nouns
or commands to the server
rather than having to call
service methods directly,
and by doing that,
you can queue up your commands,
and then send them all at once
to the server.
And I've written a couple
articles on my blog
about using gwt-dispatch
to do that,
or you can now use
RequestFactory,
which is our new
RPC capability in GWT,
and RequestFactory has built-in
batching support.
So with GWT 2.3,
you just call RequestContext
dot whatever your method is,
and instead of calling fire
immediately,
you call the dot 2 method,
and then after all of those
are accumulated,
then you call dot fire,
and that just makes one trip
to the server.
With GWT 2.4, which the beta
came out this week,
you could actually do this
across services, as well,
using the requestContext.append
method.
So that's a good way, again,
to minimize the chattiness
of your application
to the server
and thereby improve
its responsiveness.
Number 4--Watch out
for RPC type explosion.
So this one affects
not so much runtime performance
as compile time.
Basically, RPC, because
it supports polymorphism,
will generate a serializer
and deserializer
for each concrete type
of an interface
in an inheritance hierarchy,
and so you end up with--
if you have large
inheritance hierarchies,
you end up with lots of
serializers and deserializers,
and that takes a lot of time
to the compile process.
It also increases the size
of your JavaScript download,
um, unnecessarily,
in some cases.
So our recommendation here
is to prefer concrete types
to interfaces
when you're using RPC,
so in--ordinarily, in Java,
you would use a list
rather than an array list,
specifically,
but it turns out,
it's better for RPC--
if you're sending that
over the wire,
you should actually
just use the array list
unless you really do need
to make it, at some point,
other types of lists.
You can also blacklist
RPC types
so that no code will be
generated for those,
if you know
you're not gonna use 'em,
and the details on that, you can
look on the GWT issue tracker,
um, in 4438.
We need better documentation,
but I needed something quick
for the slide,
so there you have it.
Also, consider
RequestFactory instead.
This is the new RPC layer,
and it will
support polymorphism.
It's not there yet,
but it will support it
in a way that doesn't cause
these type explosions,
because RequestFactory
doesn't have to generate
a serializer and deserializer
for every class, like RPC does.
And finally,
for the performance pitfalls,
number 5, don't use a widget
when HTML will do.
Widgets have overhead
due to the event processing
that's required in a browser,
and anytime you add
an event handler,
then that's taking up memory
and it's slowing down
the browser a little bit.
So, uh, don't use widgets
unless you actually do need
to respond
to events from that widget.
If you're just trying to write
HTML onto the page,
then just use
plain HTML instead,
and you can do that easily
using UiBinder
with HTML tags.
Uh, but there is a caution here.
If you do need to catch an event
at some, you know, deep--
deeply nested place
in the widget hierarchy,
it does have to have a path
consisting only of widgets
back up to the top.
So you can't do, say,
all of your layout
in HTML at a top level,
and then have HTML, HTML, HTML,
and then try to attach a widget
to listen for events,
because they won't bubble up,
so if you do need 'em
at a low level,
then you should be using widgets
all the way up.
Also, you can use
the new LayoutPanels.
They're more efficient
than previous panels were
because they delegate more
to the browser
and they make less use
of tables,
so we've--we're using
more CSS layout now.
And now for lists and tables
and trees, especially,
we recommend that you use
the new Cell widgets
instead of the old
FlexTable and grid.
Those approaches,
each Cell was a widget,
but with Cell widgets,
as John will come and tell us,
uh, it's a much
lighter-weight pattern,
so John LaBanca, please come
and tell us about Cell widgets.
[applause]
LaBanca: Thank you.
All right. Um, so for those
of you who aren't familiar,
we recently,
as ofGWT 2.2, I believe,
we introduced this new concept
of Cells and Cell widgets.
So what I'm gonna talk about
today is what is a Cell,
and how does it compare
to a widget?
And then we're gonna go into
and talk about CellTable,
what it is, why it's so awesome,
and how to use it.
There are other Cell widgets.
There's CellTree, CellList,
but CellTable has by far
gotten the most use,
so we're gonna focus on that.
Okay, so Cell widgets are bas--
Cells are like
widget flyweights.
A widget creates
its DOM structure
using DOM calls
and createElement,
and then builds itself
and syncs events on itself.
All that is fairly expensive
when you do a lot of it.
A Cell, on the other hand--
you create one instance,
as you can see,
uh, in the little chart below--
that one instance generates
HTML strings.
It can create multiple,
uh, multiple DOM elements
from those strings.
Any time an event occurs on
one of those elements,
it goes back to the flyweight,
and you get the event and you
get the parent DOM element.
The benefits of this--
as Dave mentioned,
widgets have overhead,
so there's a lot less overhead,
and you can render large sets,
such as an entire table,
as a single HTML string.
Okay, so some of the features
that are currently supported--
We support paging,
multiple row selection,
keyboard navigation
and row selection,
column sorting,
and the rest of 'em,
and what we're hoping to add
by the end of this quarter
is a fixed header and footer
with a scrollable content area
in the center,
and also a fully customized
table structure,
so rowspans, colspans.
You can do things like have,
uh, expandable rows
by just creating multiple rows
and indexing,
um, everything past
the first row.
So here's a little demo.
Um, now the demo
I'm doing here--
this is the Google Web Toolkit
showcase app
that is--has been available
for a long time,
so I'm gonna do a few things.
I'm going to click
and do multi-selection.
Um, I can navigate
using the cursors,
and you can see, it's only--it's
skipping non-editable Cells.
I can click...
and change a value,
and then I can do paging,
so you can see how fast
this table pages.
Basically, as fast
as I can click on it.
Uh, and column sorting.
All right, so...
we had a little overview.
Now let's talk about
how you actually create
one of these CellTables.
So basically, creating
the CellTable widget--very easy.
You create the widget,
and then you add columns.
Create a widget.
You'll notice that, here, we've
typed it with the type Contact.
That's the row value,
the value that goes across
all the columns.
Each column will have
its own genericized type
that represents either a field
or a group of fields
in the--in the row.
The simplest column
is a text column.
It's a type String, so you don't
need to add the extra type,
and what you basically do
is you provide
this getValue method,
which says, get me the column
value from the row value,
so object or Contact dot name.
For something slightly
more complicated,
we use a date,
so a date Cell is a Cell
that will represent a date.
You can customize the format
of the date object,
and what we say is,
uh, the column is of type
Contact and Date,
so from a column row object,
get the Date,
and that's exactly what
this getValue method does.
All right, pretty
straightforward.
How do we put data
into the CellTable?
The simplest version
is what you see here.
You take a list of data
and you call setRowData,
and boom, your data will appear
in your CellTable.
But that's really only useful if
you have, you know, static data.
You just want to render a large
set, but it's not dynamic.
So a more practical use case
involves a data provider.
Now the data provider
is not a required class.
It's a convenience class.
What it's really doing is
the CellTable can fire
range change events,
and so it's listening for
the range change event,
getting the data for
the new range, and providing it,
but you'll find that these
dataProviders are pretty,
uh, are a little bit
easier to use
for some of that setup logic.
So we're gonna create
an asynchronous data provider--
I'll get to it in one second--
And then we're going
to add the table as a display
of that data provider.
Multiple tables, and you can--
you know, tables and lists,
you can use 'em jointly,
can be--can have
the same data provider
providing data for them,
so you don't have to manage
multiple requests
for the same data.
Okay, onRangeChange is called
when the table is loaded
and when the user pages,
so if they're paging through,
it might--
the range here is going to
start--let's say, 0 through 50,
and then it will go
51 through 100.
At this point, you can send
an RPC request,
or whatever you need to do,
to get the data from the server.
When it comes back,
you call updateRowData
with the new data.
One of the cool features
about CellTable
is that it's--it supports
a push model,
so you can send the request
for the first 20 rows,
then the next 20 rows,
and just update the data
incrementally,
so you don't have to wait
for a very long RPC call
to get something in front
of the user.
In addition
to AsyncDataProvider,
we also provide
ListDataProvider,
which is even simpler. You don't
have to implement anything.
It is a data provider
backed by a java.util.list,
and any modifications
you make to the list
are reflected in the table.
All right, so you've got
your table.
You've got the data
in your table.
How do you make modifications?
What we support is each column
has a field updater,
and the field updater is called
when the user interacts
with the Cell,
so if it's a button Cell
and the user clicks the button,
it calls the field updater.
And the parameters that
are passed to update,
um, there's some--the index
and general stuff.
The contact here is
an unmodified row value.
The date, the new birthday,
is the new column value,
so if it's a text field,
the--the new birthday
would be the new text.
What we do is we call
our RPC service,
we send the row value
and the new data,
and then, on success,
we knew that it's been
a successful change,
we call contact.setBirthday.
We update our local cache,
wherever you store that,
and redraw the table.
And so with this model,
in the meantime,
your cell can go into a pending
state if you want it to.
You can do a lot
of different things,
and when we redraw,
because CellTable is so fast,
um, even if you have 50 rows
and 10 columns,
you should be able to redraw
so fast that it doesn't matter
that you're redrawing
the whole table.
If you have a very large table
and you want to make sure that
you only redraw that one value,
you want to optimize
for performance.
Instead of redrawing
the whole table,
you can set--you can push
that new value to the table
by calling setRowData
with a singletonlist.
The key here,
the reason this isn't
the obvious first choice
is that in the asynchronous
RPC call,
the index could change,
so if the user deletes a row
while you're updating
another row,
um, the index will be off,
so you have to manage that
in your own app logic,
and for some, it will
be easier than others,
but this is an optimization.
And with that, I will
hand it back to Dave,
who's gonna talk
about code splitting
and Activities and Places.
[applause]
Chandler: Thanks, John.
So GWT 2.1 released
a new application framework
that used Activities and Places,
and we want to cover that
this morning,
this afternoon,
whatever time it is.
It's been a long
couple of months.
Um, in order
to help you understand
how you can use it
with code splitting.
Code splitting, you're probably
familiar with,
the GWT.runAsync.
This is a way to break
your application up
into parts of JavaScript,
individual scripts,
where each one only gets loaded
as it's actually needed,
and this can
dramatically improve
the load time
of your application
by reducing the amount of code
needed on the first page.
So what I'm gonna show you here
is how to use Activities
and Places,
and then we'll look at how
to use Activities and Places
with code splitting,
specifically.
So Activities and Places
helps you manage history,
your browser's history,
bookmarks,
and the evil "back" button.
What happens if you
are building a Web app
and it's an AJAX app,
it's mostly JavaScript,
and unless you do something
special in your app,
what happens
when the user comes up
and clicks the "back" button?
Your app goes away,
because it goes back to whatever
page they were on, right?
So users don't think
that's the way
applications should work,
and so GWT has had
for a long time in it,
uh, the history object,
which lets you put
a token on the URL,
and there's a special
little iframe
that you put in your host page
that listens for events,
listens for changes
to the browser history,
and then can update the state
of your application.
It's then difficult
to use history directly.
It takes a little more thought,
and so there are lots
of frameworks that emerged
um, MVP frameworks, like
gwt-presenter and gwt-platform,
that will do this
history management for you
through the notion of Places.
Well, now we have
our own notion of Places
in GWT itself.
And you might ask,
What does this have to do
with model-view-presenter?
So there's been
some confusion about this.
I apologize for this.
Uh, some of the confusion
is our fault
because we originally
conflated some concepts,
and the MVP pattern,
strictly speaking,
view and presenter
doesn't have anything to do
with place
and history management.
However, those two topics were
originally presented together
on this stage,
um, a couple years ago,
in the same presentation,
and so people began
to commonly refer to MVP
as place/history management,
as well.
And it turns out that framers
like gwt-presenter
and gwt-platform--it actually
makes a lot of sense
and is very convenient,
if you've defined
a presenter in your app,
to just be able to annotate
and have it take on the notion
of place, as well,
and have the framework
automatically handle,
um, the URL transitions when you
navigate to and from a place.
With Activities
and Places now, though,
I'm gonna separate
those concepts.
We're not talking
about MVP proper here.
We're talking about
browser history management.
Okay, let's do a quick demo
of Places in action here,
so you can see this.
This is the Expenses sample app,
which is in the GWT trunk,
and it uses Places.
So you'll notice,
uh, the URL here.
We're just at our load page,
expenses.html,
but when I click on one
of these detail items,
the URL changes,
and now we have some I.D.
and a full class name in there.
Okay, that's our Place.
It's in response
to a Place change.
So if I bookmark this place--
we'll just copy it
to the clipboard here
and pull up a new browser tab
and copy that in
and then go directly there,
it loads our app and takes us
immediately to that Place.
That's what we're talking about
um, with the notion of Places.
So how do we make this work
in GWT 2.1 and following?
Okay, first, some definitions.
A Place just represents
a bookmarkable state.
A PlaceController is a GWT class
that makes the "back" button
and bookmarks
work like you expect.
It's what actually does
the interaction
with the GWT history object.
And a PlaceTokenizer
is something that you write
that tells GWT--
how do I convert from the state
of my Java object
to a String that can be
put on the URL,
or, conversely, from that string
back to the Java object
representing a Place?
So here's an example of a Place.
This one extends the Place
class, which is now in GWT,
and the main part of it,
really, is the Tokenizer.
The two methods are required.
We have getPlace and getToken,
and these just--
you tell GWT how to translate
the Java to a string
and vice versa.
That's--that's basically it
for Places.
It's very simple. It is
a little bit of boilerplate.
It would be nice if we would
generate these Tokenizers
automatically,
and you can expect to see
future work related to that
down the road.
Some of the other frameworks,
like gwt-presenter,
use annotations
and then GWT generators
in order to take care
of this for you,
and it would be nice if we did
something similar in GWT.
How do you tell GWT
about all of your Places
in your app?
You do that using
a PlaceHistoryMapper.
This is a simple
marker interface.
It has no actual methods
or code in it,
but the annotation
@WithTokenizers
is where you point
to the Tokenizer class
for each Place in your app.
You just list them all out,
and then GWT automatically
registers them
in its infrastructure.
The PlaceHistoryMapper is
the interface that you extend,
and there's also
a factory version of this,
called
PlaceHistoryMapperWithFactory,
and if your Tokenizers require
arguments in their constructors,
then you need--you'll need
to use the factory version
instead of this interface.
Okay, let's look
at the moving parts.
What actually happens here?
Let's say you want to cause
the view to transition,
go to a new Place,
so you call the
PlaceController.goTo method.
That results in a PlaceChange
event being fired.
It goes to the EventBus.
The PlaceHistoryHandler,
which is a GWT class,
uh, listens for that event,
and then it calls
History.newItem,
which actually puts the URL
on the browser's address bar.
Going backwards, when the user
uses the "back" button
or goes to a bookmark,
that causes the History
ValueChangeEvent to be fired.
The PlaceHistoryHandler
picks that up,
calls PlaceController.goTo
the new place,
and Affects
the Place transition.
Okay, Places are designed
to be used with Activities.
They don't have to be,
but it's useful.
So if you don't use them
with Activities,
you would have to listen for
these PlaceChangeEvents
in your app yourself,
and then change the view
however you need to
based on those events,
but if you use the Activities,
then there's a little more stuff
that GWT will do for you.
So the terminology is taken
from Android development.
An Activity just represents
something that the user
is doing.
We say it handles wake-up,
setup, and show-up,
so it's kind of managing
the state of the user's actions
with respect to a particular
part of the UI.
So one of the nice features
of Activities
is that they can automatically
warn users before leaving,
so if they use
the "back" button, let's say,
a warning box
will pop up and says,
this Activity is stopping.
Do you really want to stop?
And you can control
the message, of course.
If you have multiple
Activities running on your--
on your screen--we'll look at
an example of that in a minute--
uh, then all of those
Activity stop messages
will just get appended
to a single warning box.
Now Activities are started
and stopped
by an ActivityManager.
and you have one ActivityManager
per panel on your screen,
so you can have
multiple Activities going
all at the same time.
They take care
of instantiating the view
for a particular area
of the screen,
and they can be presenters
uh, in MVP parlance,
but they don't have to be.
It's really intended to be
a higher-level concept.
But an Activity
can be associated
with a Place, as well.
We'll look at that all
in a minute
in a big, complicated diagram.
So here is a typical Activity.
This extends
the AbstractActivity,
which is just
a convenience class.
The real requirement
is just to implement
the Activity interface,
but this class provides
default implementations
of a lot of your methods
for you.
The most important method
is the start method.
This is where it all happens.
Notice that it takes a panel
of type AcceptsOneWidget,
so this is what enforces
the requirement that an Activity
is responsible for managing
one area of the screen,
and then it also
takes an eventBus,
which is the bus
that your app uses
to communicate with other parts
of the app.
So you call panel.setWidget
with your view,
and that then brings,
um, that results in GWT
calling "add widget"
to that container,
so this is what actually
makes your view show up
on the screen.
An ActivityMapper
is what you use
to tell GWT, when this Place
transition happens,
here's the Activity to load,
so it has only one method,
called getActivity.
It takes a Place,
and your code will typically
look something like this.
If it's one type of Place,
then you return
the corresponding Activity.
You'll have one ActivityMapper
for each region
of the screen, typically.
We'll look at that
in just a second.
Okay, so a couple of
ActivityMapper idioms here.
Your code can return
a new activity
each time the getActivity method
is called,
in which case, your Activities
are completely disposable,
and this makes your code
the cleanest
because you're not having
to clean up the state each time.
Each time, you're just getting
a brand-new activity,
and all the state is gone
from previous views
for that Place.
Uh, but you can also use
a singleton Activity,
where you might obtain it
from dependency injection,
from GIN, let's say,
or from your own factory,
and in that case, you would
just call an update method
on your singleton Activity
and tell it about the new Place,
and then you have to do
the state cleanup.
Okay, so how does this all
work together now?
Places and Activities?
Let's say you call
PlaceController.goTo.
Again, it fires
the PlaceChangeEvent,
which gets picked up
by the ActivityManager.
The ActivityManager
asks your ActivityMapper,
"What activity
goes with this Place?"
and then it calls the mayStop
method on the old Activity
that was running
in the area of the screen.
If it allows it to stop,
then the ActivityManager
will start the new Activity.
The only piece that you write is
the Activity itself, of course,
and the ActivityMapper.
All these other classes
are fundamental GWT classes.
So how can you divide
a screen into regions
and have one Place transition
result in multiple
Activity transitions?
Let's look at the right side
of the screen first.
We have the List
Activity Manager
and the Details
on the top and bottom.
These would be
two different Activities
running in their
respective panels,
so each has its own manager,
and each will have
its own mapper,
but there would only be
one PlaceChange.
So in this case,
the URL would probably have
something like
detailrecordid=34,
and then all three
of these things
would be listening
for the PlaceChangeEvent
and would make
the transitions appropriately.
So the two on the right
are wired up with Places
and Activities,
so your ActivityMapper would say
if place instanceof DetailPlace,
then return new DetailActivity,
and that would result
in the bottom of the screen
being updated.
Similar for the top,
with the List Activity,
and then, on the left side,
this is a permanent feature
of our screen.
It doesn't actually change
with respect to each Place.
The navigation is always there,
so it doesn't even need
to be an Activity.
It can just listen for
PlaceChangeEvents directly.
That's why we have
PlaceChangeHandler over there.
You could make it an activity,
but it doesn't really
buy you anything.
You just listen for
the PlaceChangeEvents
and then update the UI,
showing a new selected item.
So that's how you can have
the notion of a composite Place.
You just have one Place,
but then you can have
each Activity
respond to that PlaceChange.
And this slide just summarizes
that in words,
so each region has
its own ActivityManager
and ActivityMapper,
all the ActivityManagers
will get notified
when the Place changes,
and then each Activity
can update its own region
or view appropriately.
So Activities, I said,
can be disposable.
Places are disposable, as well.
They're designed
to be throwaway objects.
Each time the URL changes,
that's gonna be a new Place
object in your GWT code.
Views, however,
you don't want to make
disposable, typically,
for performance,
because view creation
is expensive,
because you're touching
the DOM in the browser,
so the best idea is
to have your Activities
obtain the views
from some kind of factory,
either dependency injection
or a factory you create,
and that way, you're minimizing
the amount of time
required to do that.
Okay, now we come
to code splitting.
This is what--this is
the good part.
This is why we are doing
this new Activities and Places.
We'd like to be able
to defer code downloads
until we actually need 'em,
and this capability has been
in GWT ever since 2.0,
the GWT.runAsync.
So you make a runAsync call,
and anything
in the onSuccess method
will be deferred
until it's actually encountered.
The GWT compiler
is actually very smart.
It sees this construct
in your code,
and then follows
the call hierarchy
from within the onSuccess method
and it packages everything
that's called
inside that onSuccess method
into a separate JavaScript.
and it only goes after
that separate JavaScript
when it's actually triggered.
So a common thing to do
is to break your application up
into a tabbed panel interface,
for example,
and make each tabbed panel
EventHandler
call the on--have
the runAsync call
that will end up with onSuccess
getting called
and only then goes and loads
the view for that panel.
There's a class that not many
people know about,
called the AsyncProxy class
in GWT,
that can help you with this,
because it can actually
turn an Async call
into one that looks
like a synchronous call,
so if you use the AsyncProxy,
uh, it can help you navigate
some of the difficulty
of the code here with runAsync.
And I just want to point out
that you can use
the -compileReport option
in order to find out
what the effectiveness
of your runAsync splits
has been.
So you should always do this,
because you'll be surprised.
Sometimes you think
you're splitting code
in a way that makes sense,
and you'll find out
you're actually not making
much difference at all.
So you run compileReport,
and then look in the soycReport
directory that it creates,
and you'll get a nice view of--
how--the total size
of each split point.
So how do we do code splitting
with Activities and Places?
Well, what we've found
on Google projects
that have been using this
is that an Activity is
a very natural split point.
It turns out to be
not too big, not too small,
it's easy to understand,
and it more or less corresponds
to something the user
is doing in the UI,
so it's a good--
it's a good place.
So you might have, for example,
in a multi-tabbed interface,
each tab might have
its own Activity,
and then you would split
on the Activity
in order to defer download
for that tab.
So with GIN, you want to use
the AsyncProvider,
uh, class that's part of GIN,
and it's actually
being moved into--
the interface is being moved
into GWT, as well,
so you don't have a dependency
on GIN, necessarily.
So your getActivity method
in your mapper
would probably have
something like this.
It would return
the activityAsyncProvider.get--
that's the standard method
on the AsyncProvider--
and that would then cause
your activity to be loaded.
GIN, if you use this approach,
and why it's nice,
is that GIN will generate
the runAsync call for you,
so you don't even have
to have that block.
Now if you want
to do without GIN,
then you're gonna want
to create a proxy class
that's going to proxy
the Activity start method,
and so you would--
whenever your Activity proxy
class start method gets called,
then it would put in
the runAsync block,
which would make the real call
to obtain your Activity.
There is some work in progress
on this still.
If you look at issue 5129,
there's extensive discussion
about different possible
approaches, and we're still
looking at which one
we're actually gonna commit to,
uh, the GWT trunk
to make this a little easier,
but you can write your own, and
the recipes are all up there.
It's just too detailed
to put on a screen.
Okay, lastly, let's look
at some compiler tips.
We hear quite often from people,
uh, doing large projects,
that GWT projects can take
several minutes to compile.
We've--sometimes
10 or 20 minutes--
uh, really large projects
using a lot of permutations,
even larger.
So the reason is,
is because GWT creates
permutations for each browser,
which is custom JavaScript code
specific for that browser,
which is the most efficient code
for that browser,
because we've tweaked
the JavaScript in order to know
about the browser's
particular idiosyncrasies
and speed improvements
that are possible, et cetera.
Which is great
for user experience,
because the user gets
the fastest experience they can,
but it does mean
that you're having
additional compile time
for your app.
So one technique
when you're using--
prior to your final
production compile--
is just to set a single
user-agent property
in your gwt.xml,
so you're only compiling
one browser permutation
for the one that you normally
develop with,
and as your project gets larger,
you'll appreciate
the benefit of this more.
You can also do the same thing
with locale,
because permutations
get multiplied together,
so if you have
five browser permutations
and four languages, or locales,
that's gonna result
in 20 permutations.
So if you're using
multiple properties this way,
you definitely want
to be restricting them
when you're doing your ordinary
development compiles.
Of course, I should have said
at the beginning,
you shouldn't be compiling
as a normal part of development.
You should be using
development mode,
when your changes take place
right away. [chuckles]
Um, avoid RPC type explosion.
Just a reminder there, as well.
This is not something
you can deal with easily
in your gwt.xml, except for
the RPC blacklisting...
But be thinking about it as
you design your RPC interfaces.
So these are a couple things
to improve your compile time.
Now draftCompile is an option
that you can add,
and it allows you to skip
a lot of the optimizations.
So you wouldn't want to use that
for your final
production compile,
but this will typically--
well, we'll show some numbers
here in a second.
Okay, so I put together
a simple little app,
and this is where I do
my eye candy demo.
It's just got 12 classes,
and I ran
some different numbers,
so let me just show you
the app first,
so you can see a little bit, uh,
of what we're dealing with.
It's called Spirodraw.
I like math, and I like
polar coordinates.
It was one of the things
that got me into programming
on the Apple IIe
in seventh grade,
so I made my high school
Java students
that I'm teaching this year
do a little animation
with polar coordinates
so they could see
these equations.
So here, we can change
the numerator and denominator
for, uh, actually, that last one
looked pretty good.
Let's go with that, um,
on a standard
"r"equals cosine "n"theta,
and it draws it out.
This is using GWTCanvas,
and I'm really not supposed
to be talking about this.
I'm supposed to be talking about
performance, but it's cool.
[laughter]
Chandler: [laughs]
And what's even cooler
is this little gizmo,
which we animated also
with GWTCanvas,
and you can come in here
and set the wheel size
and the colors
to change the shape
of the, uh, the graph,
and you probably had a toy
like this when you were a kid
and thought it was great,
but you got annoyed with it
whenever the paper would slip,
and it would make your drawings
not beautiful anymore.
Well, here, the paper
never slips, right?
[laughs] So you can enjoy it.
So this is
my little Spirodraw app.
It's spirodraw.appspot.com.
and, uh, you can do that
for the rest of the presentation
if you get bored with me.
So 12 classes, very simple app,
but these are some numbers.
I just went through and ran
different combinations,
so just a standard compile
for all browsers
was 43.3 seconds.
If I did Safari only,
by restricting
the user-agent property,
then that took it down
to 27.7 seconds.
If I do draftCompile
and Safari only,
I could get it down
to 24.1 seconds,
so about half.
So just by restricting
the browser agent,
which is a one-liner
in your XML,
and using
the draftCompile option,
you can cut
your compile time in half,
and it'll be more dramatic
the more permutations
you have, of course.
Note that
the -compileReport option
takes it the other way.
Because it's generating
a lot of extra data for you,
it will add time
to your compile,
so be careful
when you're doing development.
You don't want to do that
every time through.
Okay, now that's
how to speed up compiles.
What about shrinking
the resulting JavaScript?
There's quite a few things
you can do,
uh, some lesser-known options
in GWT to do this.
So one of them is called
the -XdisableClassMetadata,
and this is an option
you can pass to the compiler
which will cause the compiler
to not generate
some extra JavaScript that
does just class cast checking.
And if you're not using
a lot of class cast checking,
uh, in your code,
or if you can tolerate
class cast violations,
basically,
then you can use this
and save some resulting size.
Similar, the--sorry, I got
my two methods mixed up.
That was class cast cheshing--
cat--checking.
I was talking
about class metadata.
You have to be careful
with this one,
because it will disable
some methods.
Like, you can't call getName
on your class
if you've got this in here.
So if you use these,
they're considered -X.
They're slightly experimental.
You just want to make sure
you test your app and make sure
everything still works,
uh, if you're using
these options.
Uh, and those will show up
as a JavaScript in your--
exception in your browser.
The compiler won't warn you
if you're using these.
It just won't work.
Okay, and then -compileReport,
we already talked about--
puts the story of your compile
in the extras directory,
and that would allow you to see,
um, the largest packages,
because you can see
the size of the JavaScript
resulting from each
Java package,
so you could then
see if there's anything
that you could eliminate
or maybe combine
in order to not pay the tax
for that package twice.
Okay, some others here.
We have some parameters
you can put in your gwt.xml.
The shrink--sorry,
the compiler.stackMode.
Stack stripping, it's called,
will remove a lot of info
that can be used
in client-side stack traces,
and you can get
up to a 15% reduction,
uh, typically, from this.
There's also
a new property put in
to obfuscate the enum names,
so if you use enum types
in your app extensively,
you might want to look at this.
Um, we're talkin'
about bytes here.
You know, we're--
if you have an enum
that's like male, female
for gender,
it's 4 bytes and 5 bytes.
It's gonna go down to 0,1.
So you're not gonna save
a whole lot of space,
but if you use it a lot,
you might save a little.
Um, we'll have a number
on that here in a sec.
CssResource.obfuscationPrefix--
uh, this is another thing you
can do to shorten up the names
when you're using ClientBundle
and CSS Resources.
There's a couple resources
listed here.
You can look at the GWT FAQ
on our documentation site,
as well as the file that's part
of the GWT distribution,
CompilerParameters.gwt.xml,
has even more parameters
that you can look at.
These are the main ones that
affect size and speed, though.
Okay, so what are the numbers
for--are different?
Again, for
our Spirodraw app here,
which does minimal casting
and has only one enum,
so we're not really testing
those very heavily here,
uh, but we see we can get
a few percent
out of the -X options,
3.8% out of stack stripping,
and if you put it all together,
you can get a 7% reduction.
Well, that's actually, uh,
that's actually pretty sizable,
in this case,
'cause we went from 280 K
down to 261 K.
If your app is a lot bigger
and uses a lot more
of these things,
you could see anywhere
from 15% to 20% reduction.
It may give you
a little extra boost
on load time.
So we've talked
about, uh, speed.
Why does it matter?
Pitfalls, Use Cell widgets,
Use Activities and Places,
Compiler tips.
I hope you've gotten
some valuable information here,
and thank you very much.
Let me take some questions
at the mics
if, uh, anybody has any.
[applause]
Chandler: Thank you. Yes.
man: Yeah, hi. I was wondering
if one of you
could speak a little bit more
about sorting with CellTable,
'cause I'm converting
to CellTable
for my own implementation,
and I was able
to get sorting working,
but it seemed a little onerous,
and I was wondering
if there was any quick, easy,
um, you know,
just 99% of the time,
I want alphanumeric
on the contents, basically.
Chandler: Okay.
LaBanca: Um, so there's a--
so at its core,
sorting is basically
a ColumnSortHandler.
I guess you've already
discovered this,
and, um, there are
a couple tricks you can do.
So it's designed to work
in two scenarios.
One is you, uh, when you sort,
you'll get--you can get
a RangeChangeEvent,
if you're sending an RPC request
to the server.
At that point, you basically
send the sort info
to the server, and the server
can do the sorting.
If you're doing it
only on the client,
um, you can provide--you can use
the ListDataProvider,
which is a java.util.list,
and what you can do is
you can associate a column
with a comparator,
and so, um, that's the simplest
it will get.
You basically say,
when this column is sorted,
use this comparator,
and if it's reverse-sorted,
it will just use the comparator
in reverse,
and, um, so you might want
to look into that.
man: Okay, thank you.
man: Is there any
documentation anywhere
on the optimize levels
in the compile?
Chandler: I don't think there's
any doc on specific levels.
man: 'Cause it says,
like, 0 to 9.
Chandler: Right.
man: Is 9 better than 0,
or is 0 better than 9?
Chandler: Oh.
man: [laughs]
Chandler: I don't know.
Which compiles faster?
man: Well, no--
specifically around,
you know, like, the size
of the compile
and all that type of thing.
Is there any benefit
of using, you know, 9,
or what's the default?
Let's put it that way.
Chandler: I believe the default
is 9, and I believe
that the draftCompile option
gives you 0.
man: Okay.
Chandler: Yeah, so I think--
In practice, I think most people
just use draftCompile.
They don't worry about
individual levels,
because probably,
if you're using draftCompile,
you're wanting it to be as--
compile as quickly as possible,
and if you're compiling
for production,
you want as much
optimization as possible,
so practically, I don't think
people actually use that.
They just use draftCompile.
man: Okay, 'cause the reason
I was asking
is there was a post somewhere
that said if you use, like, 4,
it's, like, 20% smaller
code creation than if you use 9.
I don't know if that's true,
or if that's--
Chandler: I could see that
being true for 4 versus 9,
but I would expect
that 0 would be even--
oh, sorry, sorry.
man: Yeah, it was like, 9
is larger than, like, 4.
Chandler: Yeah. Okay, yeah.
man: Just curious.
Chandler: Okay, yeah.
man: Thank you.
man: Um, at the beginning
of your talk,
you were t--
um, you mentioned that
you should only create widgets,
um, in cases where you need
events off those widgets.
Um, I'm wondering
about HTML panels,
'cause you said also
that if--if you can,
just use HTML, straight HTML,
if you don't need to put,
um, events in there.
But what if you were
to create an HTML panel
and then, you know, I.D.
some element way down there
and then add a widget to that?
Do you get any benefits
from that?
Is that
an optimization technique
that you think might fly, or...
Chandler: I think--do you know--
LaBanca: Yeah.
Chandler: HTML panels
still have some--
LaBanca: Yeah--no, abso--
but that is an optimization.
In fact, if you're
using UiBinder,
that's the way
most people use it,
is they create the HTML panel,
fill it with raw HTML,
and just use
widgets selectively.
That's the big--if you use that
throughout your app,
I mean, one is not gonna
make a difference,
but if you use it
throughout your app,
that's significantly faster
than using panels,
GWT panels, throughout,
so, definitely.
man: Okay, thanks.
Chandler: Question over here,
down the center aisle.
man: Okay, so I would have
two questions.
One is not certainly relevant,
but what happened to Roo?
That was a big thing last time,
and, like, I didn't hear
anything about that.
Chandler: Um, I'm not aware
of a lot of activity
around Roo, currently.
Um, I think some GWT folks--
actually, the Spring guy who is
supposed to be working with that
is here at the conference,
um, so you might ask him
what's going on with it,
um, but it's--that's
Spring's department, really,
more than--more than GWT.
man: Okay.
Second one would be, like--
you told that it's a good idea
to cache the views,
but not the presenters.
Chandler: Right.
man: But could that not, uh,
lead to some memory issues
if you cache too many views?
'Cause I get--somehow,
it's caching the memory,
like all the widgets and stuff.
Chandler: I suppose if you had,
you know, hundreds or thousands
of views,
that you could end up
eating some memory that way,
but when I say
"cache the views,"
I'm not talking about loading
them all at once, necessarily,
but just the first time
they get loaded.
Then you keep them around
as, essentially, singletons
rather than creating
new instances
every time the Place changes.
man: Mm-hmm. Okay, thank you.
Chandler: Yeah.
Okay, over here.
man: So I really appreciated
in this session
the, uh, breakdown
of Activities, Places,
views, and presenters,
and kind of seeing
how you could take pieces
and make up a page,
and then in an earlier
presentation, you talked about
views and presenters
being used for mobile.
Could I convince you to take
these sample applications
and create a mobile version
of it, so that we can see
how Activities, Places,
views, presenters,
can be put together
for your desktop
and then for mobile?
Chandler: Yeah, take a look
at the Expenses sample.
Actually, there's a mobile
version of that already.
man: Excellent.
Chandler: And I think it uses
Activities and Places.
I'm not positive.
LaBanca: Actually, the mobile
web app sample is even better.
The newest sample, um, has--
it's exactly
what you're talking about.
It uses Activities and Places,
and it has--the Activity
is the "presenter,"
and we have different views
for tablet, mobile, and desktop,
so basically, it will detect
which device you're on
and serve you the view,
but the 90% of the code
that's, like,
above the view logic
is all completely shared.
man: And so that--
what I'm wondering about
is on the desktop,
you're gonna want to have
all the pieces together,
and then on the phone,
for example,
those pieces that are all
together on the desktop
will end up being
different pages, right?
LaBanca: Um, it's the same
Places, but they look different.
man: Okay.
LaBanca: So for example,
on the desktop--
I'll tell you what
the versions look like.
On the desktop, you have a menu,
and you click
the task list or "Add Task."
if you haven't seen the app,
it's a task manager.
And so you have a task list
that's a table, a CellTable,
and then you have Add Task.
It's a form, and you can
switch between them.
On the mobile version,
it's similar,
except you have a list of tasks,
and each item has, you know,
a sort of a rich--
it has a name
and a date under it,
and when you click one,
it slides over,
and the form is more vertical
for a mobile.
And then on the tablet,
it's got them, uh, split screen,
so you have the list
always visible
and the task on the--
on the side,
and it even supports things
like rotating the mobile device
and the tablet.
man: Excellent.
That sounds exactly
like what I'm wondering about.
Thanks.
Chandler: That code
is located right here.
I've got it up on the--
it's under the, uh,
in trunk, samples,
mobile web app.
Question from this mic.
man: Yeah, so, um,
Cells are awesome from
a performance perspective,
but they don't really compare
to widgets in terms of,
uh, being able to, you know,
add styles and attributes
and basically muck with them,
uh, very dynamically.
And given that Cells
kind of seem to be the future
with--with the new widgets
and all of this,
uh, do you think, um, you know,
ever get Cells to a point
where it doesn't require,
you know,
a brand-new Cell implementation
with, you know, innerHTML stuff
and your own, you know,
dispatch and stuff,
just to, you know, add something
that the Cell up front did not--
you know, most of them will
sometimes take style name,
but, you know, nothing really
other than that,
um, if you know what I mean.
LaBanca: Yeah, the first set
of Cells were very rudimentary,
and we intentionally
didn't expose any styles
so that we could add them later,
'cause if we exposed them now,
we'd be stuck with 'em.
So the answer is yes, we plan
to expand the library,
and to focus on ClientBundle
and, uh, CSS resources,
so they'll be a little bit
more difficult--
well, okay, admittedly, they'll
be more difficult, um, to style,
because you have to specify
your styles in a CSS resource,
but, um, when you do that,
the GWT compiler is--
can optimize those
and obfuscate the names,
so it actually gives you
a performance benefit,
and so, over time, we're gonna
expand that library
and make it more customizable,
ad we're following a pattern.
The only one in there now
is the, um, the button widget
has been modified,
or the "text" button.
But we're following
a pattern where it's--
we gwt.create all
of the, um, the resources
and the view version of that,
the appearance pattern,
we call it.
And so what that means is that
third parties can provide skins
that not only replace the styles
but the actual DOM structure,
so your button can go
from being a button element
to some nested divs
to whatever else you want.
And we're hoping that takes off,
but we have not yet really
started to expand that library.
man: Sure, sure. I-I perhaps
overemphasized style,
um, and what
I was talking about.
Widgets are also just really--
since they're stateful,
it's very easy to intuitively,
you know, modify them,
you know, adding children,
removing children,
uh, setting things
that aren't style-related,
like titles or values
or whatever.
Uh, it's just a very stateful
and intuitive model
that I don't quite see
yet in Cells,
um, but would
definitely like to.
Obviously, I understand you
don't have states, so that...
Chandler: Yeah, I think it's--
if I can speak to that, I think
it's pretty much implicit
in the flyweight pattern.
If you're writing out HTML,
it--it's gonna be ugly,
but that's how you get
the performance benefit
associated with
the--the Cell widgets.
LaBanca: And one thing
that's coming down the pipe
is a UiBinder for Cells,
so that--that will help a lot,
so instead of having
to construct the HTML
from an object,
using, uh, StringBuilder
or SafeHtml Builder,
you could just put it
into a UiBinder XML file
and sort of write the raw HTML,
and then replace parts
with the values
that you want to replace
so that should help.
Chandler: Question over here.
man: Yeah. We start
to use CellTable,
and it's nice
and very easy to use
and also has a custom column,
so you can create
your own column type,
and, uh--but we have some
problems with alignment.
I don't know--it's the way--
we didn't use it properly, or--
because some columns
won't align to the left,
some to the right,
and it works in some browsers
and doesn't work
in other browsers.
Is it a known issue,
or something we didn't do right?
LaBanca: The text aligns
on different sides?
man: The--yes, alignment,
uh, for the column.
LaBanca: By default,
we don't adjust alignment,
so the browser just chooses
the alignment.
It may vary between browsers.
Chandler: It does.
LaBanca: And they may even
do creative stuff
like move numbers over to one
side but text over to the other,
but there is a, uh--
man: Exactly.
LaBanca: In a column, have you
tried using the setAlignment?
man: Yes, we tried, but--
LaBanca: Didn't work?
man: It worked in some browsers,
but it doesn't work--
LaBanca: Okay, you can
file a bug and we'll take a--
that should fix it
in all browsers.
man: Okay, my other question
is related to the Activities.
We started to use that, as well,
and the warning, you know,
pop-up is very nice
when the user wants to,
um, when they click
the--the "back" button,
but sometimes, we want
to pop up a new window,
and for example, pop up a new
window to an external URL,
and that warning also pops up.
Is there any, you know, bypass
or workaround with that?
We don't want--we don't want
to show that pop-up
when they try to open
a new window,
go to another URL.
Chandler: Uh, you have
the onMayStop method,
where you provide
your warning message,
so you could override
that method and make it,
uh, you know, set some kind
of flag in there,
that it could look at
to determine
whether or not you wanted
to show the message.
man: Um--
Chandler: Is that--
because if you return "true"
from--no, sorry.
You would be looking
at the, uh--
yeah, it's onMayStop, I think.
If you return "true" from that,
then it will--
um, it will let it
go ahead and stop,
and it won't pop
any warning message at all.
man: Give example--
uh, on your screen,
maybe you have
a button to click,
and that will open up
a new pop-up window,
go to an external URL...
Chandler: Mm-hmm.
man: Would even leave
this page, anyway,
but the pop-up--and the warning,
you know, comes out,
and asks you, do you want to
stay and do you want to leave?
I mean, is there any workaround
for that, or...
Chandler: That--no, I can't
remember which method it is,
exactly, but it's--
I think it's onMayStop...
man: Okay.
Chandler: End the Activity,
and if you return
the right thing,
it's either "no" or "true"
or something like that,
but then it will
allow it to stop
without putting up
any kind of a warning message.
man: Okay, I'll look into.
Thank you.
Chandler: Yeah. Question?
man: Yeah. When I've inspected
some of the JavaScript
that's generated,
um, you know how it
kind of goes,
uh, shortest method
to longest method,
there seems to be an awful lot
of methods that are just empty.
I'm not sure if that's,
um, just some coding style
that just seems to be pervasive
in projects that
I've seen 'em in,
but I noticed this like,
you know, 40 just
totally empty methods,
and I'm thinking,
there's probably gotta be
some compiler setting
that gets rid of those?
I don't know
if maybe they're there
as an obfuscation technique
to sort of throw people off.
I don't really know,
but I do notice them
consistently in there,
and I wonder if that's something
that we can get rid of.
I mean, it's, like,
three characters
or, yeah, four characters
apiece, so it's not huge,
but there are 40 or 50 of 'em,
so does that sound familiar
at all? Do you see that...
Chandler: I remember
seeing an issue on this
uh, on the issue tracker,
actually.
Did you file that issue?
man: No, I didn't.
Chandler: [laughs] Okay.
Um, so someone else
has observed it.
man: Good.
Chandler: And I don't remember,
uh, I don't remember
the details, honestly.
I know it's out there.
You might see whatever responses
were on that issue,
but it has been
pointed out before.
man: Okay. I haven't
looked in 2.3.0,
but I mean, about 2.1 and 2.2,
I noticed 'em, but...
Chandler: Yeah, I-I think there
are some pathological cases
where that happens.
It's--and we're trying not
to do that, ordinarily,
um, but, yeah, without looking
at the actual code, whatever,
it's hard to say.
man: Okay, thanks.
Chandler: Yes.
man: So closely related
to code splitting is the ability
to defer loading of third-party
JavaScript libraries.
Is there any thought
to providing that API,
or did I miss it?
LaBanca: I don't think
we have that...
man: Okay.
LaBanca: Obviously.
Chandler: Yeah.
man: Have you thought about it?
LaBanca: What you're basically
talking about
is a script widget, if you will,
with a LoadHandler.
I mean, that's what
it would amount to,
um, and it's not on anybody's
radar, as far as I know,
but if it would be useful,
probably something
that could be done.
Chandler: Yeah.
man: In our case,
the third-party library
is larger than our app,
and we use it less
than 20% of the time,
so there are cases where
it would be very useful.
LaBanca: Do you want--
uh, if you just want to defer
the loading of it,
you can use runAsync,
and in your runAsync call--
well, that's not really
what you want.
Um, I mean--yeah, I'm not sure.
I don't have a good answer.
I'd be making stuff up.
man: Okay.
Chandler: Last question,
over here. Yep.
man: Now to--to
this runAsync topic,
so you mentioned that we can
inject, like,
inject it with GIN,
like, to annotate it, and what
happens if it cannot load?
Is there some error handling
for that?
Chandler: Yes, you also provide
an onFailure method
uh, in your runAsync block.
man: Oh.
Chandler: And
the onFailure method--
then you control what happens.
man: Okay.
[speaking indistinctly]
Okay, thanks.
Chandler: Okay, thank you
very much.